like why does life need to be meaningful
it doesn't I mean a lot of Olympians
have huge depression after they get a
gold because now what like of course if
doesn't make you happy you suck at it on
the dayto day like what is that that
make you feel happy well right off the
bat I don't optimize for subjective
well-being I do that more for the
audience I that's never been a goal of
mine um I think when I was 19 or 20 I
said happiness and I've pretty much
stuck with that
um there's two two concepts I'll I'll
I'll bring up on this so one
is people who want to be happy treat it
like I want to eat so good I'm never
hungry again or I want to sleep so well
I never need to sleep again but I think
happiness is is much more like that than
it is this this achievement thing that
you like check a box off it doesn't
really work that way secondly I think
that all the people that I know who
obsess about happiness are the least
happy people
outwardly sure but they're the ones who
are like committing suicide I I worry
about that because that it's a goal that
by having it as a goal it automatically
sits outside of you which means there's
space between you and the goal which
means you're not actually happy my goal
is to be happy which means you aren't
right
now
so I have
made meaning which is ironic because I
don't find things inherently meaningful
but I have F I have found meaningful
work as I deem meaningful um to be the
thing that I derive the most Joy from
and so I have it broken down to a more
tactical level which is what days have I
enjoyed and looked back on and been
proud of myself for that day and over
probably a three or four year period I
just looked at the good days and the bad
days and I looked at what the good days
had in common and looked at what the bad
days had in common I've just over time
minimized the things that happen on the
bad days and maximized the things happen
on the good days even even to Big
Investments like I am much happier when
I work
out like rather not even much happier
when to workout when I look back on my
day this was a good day almost always
has a workout in it and usually with
people I like and so workouts take
probably longer for me than most people
because I'm not the uh I'm in and out in
45 minutes and I you know you know did
my my morning routine and I can do send
out 40 emails from whatever it's every
everyone's different but for me I work
out for like two hours it's because I
like
to and so I do it and I do it with
people that I like and so I'm willing to
invest the time because like what's the
point anyways like why make all the
money to what enjoy it like I enjoy
doing that so I do that every day um I
like writing so I write for you know
four to six hours a day um and those
probably the two biggest activities that
I do and if I can write with somebody
that I like then I I do something I like
with people I like and I think that
that's probably been the the S the
single simplest formula is doing things
you like with people you like and trying
to maximize as much time as I can on the
on that bucket and then everything else
I try and minimize is overhead or
Outsource most people are like why am I
not happy they also see a problem with
them not happy they have it as an
expectation of the world and the
universe that they should be happy right
and to the same degree people have an
expectation that life should be should
be meaningful like why does life need to
be meaningful why does the universe need
to make you happy it doesn't you can
choose that but it's just like not a
requirement and so they think there's
something wrong with it when in reality
like you're alive and you might
procreate you might not but like that's
the only reason that you're
here right oh man there you go broke my
wedding
ring it's a
sign name I don't know silicon it's like
my third one I break him every like two
years as a side note this is
incredible oh cool really good oh
okay whatever you took take that
again
on smells like commitment I
I so like if I if I boil it down like
happiness is is fleeting because you get
hungry again you get sleepy again um
meaning you can only really tell at the
end like did I do something that that
contributed but on the day-to-day
perspective I can know that what I'm
doing is useful and if what you're doing
is not useful then I think that that's
harder and I also think I also think
think that men and women are different
here so we use like H happy I hate the
term in general but like I think men and
women want different things out of life
and I think we we bucket them together
it's also the same degree like why um
therapy with men um doesn't work
necessarily the same we have to have a
different approach like people think men
need more love and I just don't think
that's true I think we want more
respect and like you get respect from
being
useful and
so I I I make that the goal like no one
casts aside a man who is
useful and being useful is an attractive
trait like if you see someone who's
really good at something it's hard like
for you like women like that is a it's a
contributing member of society they do
stuff like that help other people we
want them here like you get status from
that and so that means that skill
Mastery in a very real way
can help you attract the meate you want
which is why I indexed a ton of my life
around getting better at stuff so like
and also from a stress perspective
people are like I remember I see
sometimes these podcasts from from
successful entrepreneurs and and they're
like man I'm still worried I could lose
it all tomorrow I don't have that like
I'm genuinely not afraid of losing it
all tomorrow because I have lost it
before and I got it back and the thing
it's like if you have a like if you were
lucky cuz there are guys who get lucky
and if you are lucky then absolutely
should be worried about it because if
you do lose it you don't know how to get
it back but if you have skills then like
I know that I can go to any business and
help grow it like it and that's valuable
that's useful and so even reframing the
word value as usefulness is probably
also an easier way to do it for people
to kind of like comprehend but I think
if you make that the goal it also takes
it away from you so the reason I hate so
there's a I would say a friend is um
well I have a friend who who's who's
single and struggles because he's not
happy successful but not happy and so he
obsesses on happiness and I was like do
you know that when you obsess on
happiness all you do is think about you
all
day it's all you're doing you're just
thinking about you all
day and like how
useless and so the nice thing with being
useful is that in order to be useful you
have to be useful to other people like
no one can be useful on their own you
have to be useful to other people so
there's a service element but there's
also a self-improvement element which is
to be useful to other people you need to
improve yourself and so that's why I
think being useful is has been probably
my day-to-day goal of what I need to do
and that serve me well um not saying
anyone should or should they can do
whatever they want but for me that's
helped me it for sure offers Clarity
they've done brain scans people with
depression and the areas of the brain
that are responsible for like
self-reflection and rumination are like
overly active yeah they think about
themselves too much um I mean this is
Tony Robbins quote he said if you stay
in your head you're dead um and because
it Rhymes it's true and
so but the uh but for real though like
when I when I was 19 the reason I said
happiness was like I realized that
I was in this cycle this Loop of trying
to like everything you analyze of like
does this make me happy does this pizza
make me happy does this class make me
happy I mean I quit Premed because I
thought biology didn't make me happy now
I'm very glad that I did cuz I like
business lot more now but like that was
the reason I did it I studied really
hard I did well but I was like this
doesn't make me happy like of course it
doesn't make you happy you suck
at it you're you're learning something
you're going to suck for a very long
time it's only when all these skills go
together that you'll be good at
something and you'll actually be useful
to Society of course you learning the
chromosomes doesn't do anything
but it's because of what it shows shows
a school that you're willing to put up
with so that you might be useful to
society in the particular skill set
um and so yeah I think being useful is
far better goal and this is this is me
just shouting out specifically to men um
if you could just just try it try try
this on for a month if you're if you're
happy do whatever the you well
really just do what everyone either way
but if what you're working isn't working
for you or what you're doing isn't
working for you um I would I would try
this on for size one say that you're
going to stop trying to be happy just
give up on it just like just stop
thinking about it like I'm not you know
what I'm actually okay with being
unhappy I'm fine with it I'm
I'm still here like it doesn't mean
anything okay and so then you can take
action despite your lack of happiness
and think okay how can I be useful to
other people and I think if you do that
you'll actually start focusing on the
tasks and on people outside of yourself
and you'll be amazed at how much better
you feel
overall and what happened to me when I
went into my happiness thing is
that I stopped thinking about happiness
altogether and then like years later I
was like you know what CU I was so used
cuz like I wanted to label myself that
way and be okay with it people would ask
me like hey XYZ I'd be like Oh I'm not a
happy person I would just like say that
up front that way I didn't have to and I
remember catching myself um probably
like 5 years later and I was like huh I
say that I was like but I actually
really do like my life a lot so I
stopped saying I'm not a happy person
cuz like I actually kind of do like my
life um but I feel like I only got to
liking my life by being willing to not
like what I was doing for a long period
of time it's like also what time frame
are you thinking about totally like most
of the things that feel good for you are
what is it feel good or bad for you in
the long run but also like things that
feel bad are probably good in the long
run I actually
um I I only disagree because it's so
vague cuz like I think people just only
think of the things that quote feel good
but there's tons of things that feel
good that are not bad for you like sex
feels good it's not bad for you you know
like it's just we immediately jump to
like cigarettes booze you know whatever
but it's really anything in excess is
bad for you like if so much sex that you
don't go to work you don't eat it's bad
for you you know what I mean if you like
even cigarettes like if you have one
cigarette or week doesn't do anything
for you probably you smoke more than
that just walking outside you know what
I mean for a week in terms of just you
know CO2 from Cars so it's it's always
you know it's always in the dose yeah is
the is maybe the usefulness of that
people want a binary when it's really
Continuum what do you mean by that
people say oh I like it therefore they
want a simple rule but like
life has way more continuums than
binaries like good and bad like first
off Define good Define bad second off
like like like it or not how much you
know to what degree how often like what
is good like whatever I mean a really
fun one is that I think um so Dr cashy
and I've talked about this but like
there was this whole thing on drinking a
glass of wine every day reserve a trol
is one of the key ingredients it's like
anti-cancer fighting whatever um but if
you look at like centenarians people
live over 100 a disproportionate amount
of them
smoke and so I find that interesting
because I think that genetically means
that that person probably has some sort
of protection against lung based
carcinogens which then means they get
all the benefits of cigarettes and none
of the
downsides and so they're able to
basically benefit from all the stress
reducing components of nicotine and
smoking but then just don't get cancer
and so I would argue that like drinking
a glass of wine every night has less to
do with the reservatrol and more more to
do with the stress reduction on a
continuous basis so anyways so like the
BL like the Blue Zone research right
like where those people live MH there
that's that's diet stuff more so more
diet stuff yeah it's more diet stuff
where do people smoke a lot everywhere
but
[Laughter]
here yeah we started it spread it
everywhere else and then said it wasn't
cool anymore and everyone else is like
what the China's like yo we still
smoke nicotine men make good
times I have a question for you do you
feel like you have a better descriptor
of the subjective experience you're
having when you're in quote unquote like
the Flow State like when you're writing
sure you wouldn't say you're happy but I
know you I know you like writing yeah
yeah I enjoy writing well I think I
think one thing is is the idea of
learning how to enjoy a challenge so I
think like I think a lot of people can
get there quickly like a lot of people
play video games because Okay so video
games are designed to increase in
difficulty proportional to people's
willingness to um basically they extend
inter interment reinforcement so your
first level is always easy and they
extend it a little bit more they extend
a little more and eventually believe it
or not you'll have learned the behavior
such that they can push it out so far
they never need to reward you again
which is why people stay in abusive
relationships like in the beginning it's
good oh I up oh everything's good
again and then I up more and then
it's good again and then I up
more and then it's good again and then
eventually it's never good again but but
they got reinforced on enough um spaces
each time that they stay in it and
so I think the difference between a
video game and life is that that
interval isn't set and so you're not
necessarily going to have a quick win at
level one because it's more like you
basically get none until you're at level
like 20 and then all of a sudden it all
comes and so that's I think that's the
difficult part and so I think being
willing I think athletes do particularly
well
um like college athletes do really well
transitioning because they've learned a
meta skill which is that you're going to
suck for a long time at something before
you become a master at it and most
people don't have the ability don't have
any experience mastering anything in
life early on and so they have to learn
how to
work and so I think um I think learning
to work is the most useful thing that
you can do I mean I think for
me I love finding input output equations
that like success of some kind so it's
like if you're giving public speaking
I'm going to give this example because
it's perfect so um Caleb who's on my
team um had said right you know years
ago when we met uh like I'm not I don't
really like public speaking I don't like
presenting I don't like any of that
stuff I was like cool and I think he
said some the degree of like I don't
like it or I'm bad at it
whatever and he did a presentation for
the team and it was good um and then uh
he had a bunch of things that he wanted
to do better on the next one
now uh between those time periods I had
done the book launch and so he had seen
me prepare for my presentation and so I
did it a 100 times over 30 days so I did
it three times a day before I gave the
book launch and you know when there was
500,000 people or whatever that were at
the launch um when we had 500,000 people
registered for the launch and I was
about to step on stage um the team that
was doing it all said we've done we do
this every day and I've never seen
anyone so like
relaxed and it wasn't a front it was
because I had done it so many times and
so fast forward Cale had another
presentation he had to give and this
time he prepared three times as long so
he did instead of 10 hours of prep he
did 30 hours of prep and instead of
having 80 slides he had 330 slides and
the presentation went way better and he
noted that he wasn't nervous at all
going into the second presentation
compared to the first presentation
and
so he messaged me afterward said
I shoot um it wasn't that I was bad at
speaking I was just
lazy and I think that a lot of people
mistakenly think they're bad at things
they haven't even learned how to try and
I do think learning how to try is also
domain specific and so like Caleb's an
exceptional video editor and media uh
strategist and and great with building
the team and those skills but those had
been skills that he knew how to work
hard at but this was a completely
different skill and so it's like writing
like I have a lot of entrepreneur
friends who who are writing books now
now they don't know that I come from
background of writing I got a full
writing scholarship uh to toughs
University which is a good school um I
got a personal letter from their writing
seller like we love all your stuff we
want you to be here I ended up going to
VB but like I was the vice editor of the
newspaper I was an Editor in Chief of
literary magazine when I was in high
school like I like writing and so I know
what hard what hard work looks like in
writing which is just editing and
editing and editing and editing which is
basically like doing the speech again
and doing the speech again and doing the
speech again and it's the same as ping
pong which is 500 backhands 500
forehands it's it's just it's just
repetition right um and so right now if
you're doing work or you feel like
you're not as good at something you have
to figure out what the input output
equation is you have to figure out like
what's the thing that I have to do a lot
of because every skills like this is
that there's a period where you have to
do a lot of something and if you don't
know what it is then you're not going to
get better sales is like I have to do
100 calls a day I have to do you know I
have to do 10 10 conversations a day
whatever it is you do that every single
day and you do that for a year you get
pretty good um and so you have
to learn what that input output equation
is so that you can push as if it's me I
once I know it then I just Jam as much
input as I possibly can into that thing
and then that's where the whole the
whole quote that you know went viral
was um confidence doesn't come from
shouting affirmations in the Mirror by
having a stack of undeniable proof that
you are who you say you are outw workk
yourself doubt and so like you become
Confident by giving yourself the stack
of evidence the hundred times I went
over the presentation I felt confident
going into that because I had a stack of
proof that I'd already done it perfectly
the last 20 times in a row that I'd done
it so why would 21 be
different and if you've had a thousand
sales calls on your thousand first if
people are watching they're like man you
sound so confident you're like it's just
how it is it's not like I'm confident I
just know I know what's going to happen
next and so I prefer to think about it
as like do it so many times you get
bored of doing it and like that's when
you'll look confident to everyone on the
outside because you'll have no emotional
affect to the outcome because you'll
have recognized the patterns so many
times that there's nothing that's going
to surprise you and I think that most
people just don't know how how to work
that hard like there is no way that
anyone will know how hard I've worked on
the books like just imagine that there's
a reason that they're all you know
alltime bestsellers for each of the
categories they're in and
still they're like it's cuz you're
following it's like no you know why I
know that look at every other
person who has a following and their
books don't sell even though
they have a big following they launch it
and then they stop selling why because
the book sucked they had a ghost writer
they voiced it in whatever and they they
make their whatever 5 million bucks or
whatever it is they publish the second
edit instead of the yeah I mean
they they like they literally they they
think the book is finished when it has
reached the number of pages that creates
a book like I can write a book in two
weeks if I was just trying to write a
certain number of pages but like I've
I've usually written five times the
amount of pages as what actually comes
out in the final draft and I've
Rewritten end to end the whole thing not
once or twice but like 10 times end to
end but you know what happens when you
do that you get really good at
knowing what is what is important what
isn't and you also give yourself way
more outside life exposures that trigger
new thoughts over that period of time
that remind you of things that can make
it better and so it's kind of like a um
like when you paint it's like it's like
putting coats of paint and letting it
dry and so I kind of see editing drafts
as like another coat of paint and then
you think you're like you know what I
just saw that like I was I was walk I
went to a new area today and I saw this
new new yellow I wonder if I could throw
that in if you had immediately shipped
it you wouldn't have had the opportunity
to see the yellow thing because time
didn't transpire during the creation of
the thing and so I think there's a
reason that books that take 10 years to
write look and read like they took 10
years to write there's just a depth to
the Quality do you then now to bring
this back kind of to like the happiness
or whatever we I find happiness in
figuring out what my input output
equation is and doing it as much as
humanly possible do you then engineer
your environment to reinforce yourself
to do more inputs absolutely how do you
do that you want to make it easy EAS as
possible to work as hard as you
can and so everything that is not that
input output equation is
interference and so like
relationships
like I mean I said this before but
everything that you are not willing to
sacrifice to be the best the person
who's best in the world is willing to
and already has
sacrificed and so I'm not saying good or
bad do whatever you want but if you want
to be number one and a lot of people say
I want to be the best it's like Nate
don't you want to be better and you can
be really good you can be really good
and not sacrifice plenty of things but
if you want to be the best then you just
have to assume that the best person in
the world has the genetic predisposition
has all the environmental environmental
cues aligned with their ultimate goal
and is willing to give up everything
that is not achieving that
goal and if you're not in that boat then
you're not going to be the best people
just like saying because makes it feel
good but it's
false um
and so in terms of aligning the
environment if you know the input out
equation so for me it's writing right
now is the season that I'm in because
writing kind of is the is the pillar of
everything else we do content wise
internal Communications the books
everything comes from me taking time to
write because I'm I organize my thoughts
better that way and i' because I've
become skilled at writing so it's the
best way it's the most succinct way that
I can communicate and so
um there's a reason that the first 6
hours of my day when I'm
freshest most well rested I have no
meetings and I have only one thing that
I do which is right there's nothing else
and so if you know what the input out
equation is find the time the four to
six hours a day every day that you can
do that and then allow nothing to
interfere with
it and that's it like nothing interferes
with it and if you do that for 5 Years
it'll be really good and you'll
be useful and you'll feel good about it
because the thing is at a certain point
the work itself becomes reinforcing like
when editors edit and then they make a
change and then and The Story Goes or
the video goes the way they want it to
it's like boom that was reinforcing and
if I like work really hard on a
paragraph and I could just shrink it to
one sentence I'm like yeah and that
might take that literally might take two
hours to just keep beating it down until
I get it to like the one most distinct
thing um but that's satisfying and so
the beginning you suck and you do the
Reps so that you learn the skills so
that eventually you do the work itself
because the work itself is rewarding but
that takes time to get
to yeah it's like you are at this point
writing the third book and it's like my
fourth book overall yes and and getting
those sentences is the is the win the
little win which also makes it easier
because then you're not waiting for the
6,000
am wonder if you could talk a little bit
to that well yeah I mean in the
beginning you start the the start the
journey because you have this big
ultimate payoff you want to have but
that's way too far out to actually wait
like you have to be an exceptional
person who's who's been reinforced in
the past for waiting for a very long
period of time that's why I say the
athletes thing is kind of interesting
because they've had to wait a long
period of time and so they have to
practice for a long period before they
get the thing um but typically they get
enough reinforcers early on that that
the act itself becomes reinforcing and
that's that's that's what Mastery is is
you transition from having some sort of
external motivator to external I believe
all motivators are external
but from the work itself being
intrinsically rewarding versus having it
carrot of some kind that's been
artificially put there like status or an
award or number one or a ranking
um and Masters
can Masters enjoy the work more than
novices do so it's actually easier for
Masters do you find ironically that hard
work has felt less hard these days or is
it still hard work because you're
pushing it
it's still hard it's different in terms
of the hard the I would say the hard
thing that I have now is that my level
of quality the standard that I have is
only mine like I know that I could
probably put out the first draft and it
would probably be a
bestseller it's just that I would know
that it could have been better and that
would eat me alive and so the hard part
is still maintain so it's actually the
hard part for me now is that I maintain
my standard as the number one standard
that I optimize for and if the world so
chooses to also like it great but it
also divorces me somewhat from the
outcome because if it were just about
getting the bestselling book then I
would publish it on the first shot
because at this point I do have enough
skill that probably would be a
bestseller on its
own but I also think there's a
difference between being a bestseller
for a season and being best seller for a
100 years and so I'm trying to write
these books to be best sellers when I'm
dead so they're still
useful how do you know when you've met
that far like how do you know when a
sentence is like when there's nothing
else I can do to it to make it better
and you sleep on it and then you wake up
the next day you look at it again
there's nothing else I can do to it to
make it better same thing for the
presentation there's nothing else I can
do to make this better I can't practice
it
more because even at a certain point
when you if you get past a certain point
of practicing you start you start
knowing it almost too well that you
start cutting corn because you're like
it it gets too natural like I actually I
borderline over prepared for the
gmats um I like peaked I CU I I I took
tests every week and my math score sorry
my English score peaked before my math
score did so my math score peaked at the
test but my English score I had done it
so many times you're like shoot and I've
done you you recognize so many patterns
that you're like man which pattern is
this one cuz like I'm so good at all of
them I have to remember like it it it um
you Peak right and so there is a point
you where it's not even diminishing
returns you actually start getting worse
um at least in my opinion or at least in
my experience and so uh if you if you if
you regress something down to its
simplest form and then I just cut the
sentence in half I lose material I lose
stuff that would that needs to be there
and so you get it as simple as possible
but no simple uh you talked about if
someone comes to you and you're like
what would you do if you had six more
hours on
that you FP back on oh yeah yeah so a
really a really fun thought exercise for
somebody who just like all of this is
like wow that's so much work I'm not
really prepared for that well I'll walk
you through what it looks like in a
micro example so if the video editor
comes to me and says hey do you like
this clip and I say yeah I do like the
clip if you had another two hours to
work on it what would you do and they're
like well if I had another two hours I'd
do this this and this I'm like okay go
do that come back they come back and I'm
like do you think it's better and they
say yeah they show it to me I'm like it
is better okay now if you had another
two hours what would you do they're like
well I do this this and this I'm like
okay cool they go they come back same
conversation like okay if you had a week
what would you do well then they're like
well shoot I would I'd probably scrap
this whole style overall and I make a
totally new framework for how I'd
approach the video um and I'd want to
come at it from this angle altogether it
would just take you know a lot more work
but I think it would still make a better
outcome it's like okay so that idea just
do it on five
years and
so everybody just wants to get it done
rather than get it
right and getting it right is where all
the money is
I bet you asked yourself like what would
you do if you had 50 years to work on
acquisition 100% I do have 50 years and
I do what I'm doing yeah and not not
trying to chase the quick reinforcement
so that sure well it's the quick
external Loop but I mean like at a
certain point you you start you start to
develop Master even around pursuing
goals so like I have I've had enough
past like this is book three from the $1
million series every month I get
thousands of reviews and DMS and people
who say their lives change from the
first two
books the hard part was book one when I
have none of that for a year and a half
but once that one's out leads I'm like
well I'm getting reinforcement every day
from my
writing and so I write and so now I have
two books worth of that and once the
third book's there'll be three books
worth of that so maintaining that gets
easier and easier just cuz I have
regular enforcement for writing not not
necessarily this book but writing in
general and so that then means I can I
can
generalize past good experiences onto
how I act and work
now that's why like you become you
become an expert at pursuing goals
because you have pursued goals in the
past I just use writing as an example
but I've pursued goals in the past and
sticking it out has had big payoffs and
so when I feel like I'm sticking it out
again I'm reminded of the past times
I've stuck it out and it's been worth it
the hard part is for the people who
haven't stuck anything out because
they've never they've never seen it work
and so the first one's always the hard
one it's like you just have to have
faith on some level you just have to
believe that it'll work out and
the the thing that carries you over the
bridge in the short term is that you are
getting better and if you can just focus
on that then even if the the crowd
doesn't cheer when you give your
presentation or you don't sell books or
whatever it is you'll know and so it's
funny because I look back at the
presentation that I gave five years ago
and I really am embarrassed
but I'm not embarrassed at the effort I
put in then because the effort I put in
then I really did think it was really
good I just didn't know what good could
be because I also gave myself 20 hours
rather than 200 hours and so if I only
had 20 hours maybe that is the best I
can do and maybe today that's still the
best I could do I just give myself way
more time but the problem with giving
yourself way more time once you see how
much good good can be is that you
realize how few projects you can
do right which is why you just have to
be that's why like the biggest guys in
biggest business Titans in the world
talk so much about Focus because it's
not it's not that like focus is the
thing it's just that it takes so much
time to do something right that
you can't do more than one
thing so it might be almost part of that
like if I know we keep saying the word
happiness but like happiness equation to
have less things that you're trying to
optimize for in in your set of things
that you're working on your life if you
want to be exceptional at something it
means you have to put a lot of input
into it and you can't be exceptional at
very many things because of how many
inputs you have and how limited they are
so if time is an input we all have the
same amount of time and if it takes a
huge amount of that time to get good at
one thing then if you take that as the
Assumption we're basing this on then
there's just not many things you can get
very good at and so then it takes some
level of selection to be like what thing
do I want to get good at how does the
one of zero brand fit into this and how
did you
conceptualize well the one of zero brand
is very much aligned with this
um I should have my nose strip on I took
it off this morning um you just pasted
it on
um the whole idea was you know it's so
funny I saw I saw the background of my
gym it said um that picture that I
posted of like one of my first video
content uh yeah it said it said the back
of the wall I made this I made this
quote up that I painted it you can see
how ugly the paint is in the back wall
it says um strength doesn't come from
what strength doesn't come from doing
doing what you think you can but doing
what you think you can't is what I think
it says which I don't agree with the
word strength it should be growth but
anyways I like the idea and so I think
that one of zero is very much like that
which is you know one of one is doing
something that only you can do one of
zero is doing something that you've
never done before and that ideally no
one else could do and so it's an amount
of work that most people just don't
comprehend and it's really hard to even
describe it because like I can say I
spent 6 hours a day for 18 months on
this one
project and people will nod their heads
but spend six hours on one thing
once and then then do it 500
times and then like you'll start to see
like the soul crushing amount of effort
that it takes to stick with
it um now I've been able to extend how
long I work on projects because just
like the abusive husband thing or the
abusive spouse thing like in the
beginning you can have a short project
you get a win I can work a little longer
the next time I can work a little longer
longer the next time books really good
books are one of the hardest projects to
do because you get almost zero
reinforcement it's very punishing for
most of the time um until quote the
end but the process itself there is some
some sort of joy in being the type of
person who is able to endure
that because I I have I have a lot of
entrepreneur friends who are like oh I
just finished my book I'm going to write
a book just like you did I was like no
you
won't no you won't cuz you know they're
not willing to put in
no they like it worked well for him I'll
do that too his book was so good I'll
write one
too doesn't work that way they've never
even written anything so they're
starting at like where I was when I was
15 and I would say the same aggree it's
probably like people who look at Mr
Beast now are like oh I'll just go make
a YouTube videos like he started with
13 and he's been spending more than six
hours a day trying to make videos since
then and so there's just like so much
depth of knowledge that you can get that
just takes time but the thing is is from
the happiness perspective I find a lot
of joy and
excellence and I think that work well
done provides dividends
forever so if we were to think about
like subjective well-being or like
purpose or meaning or utility or
usefulness any of those whatever one you
want to optimize for like I am proud of
the first book I wrote I'm proud of the
second book I wrote I'm proud of the
third book I wrote and I'm proud of the
book that I'm writing right now
and when I look back on them every time
I see them and I see people benefit from
them I get a reward for a one-time input
even though it was a year for the rest
of my life I will get rewarded for that
effort and so it just encourages me more
and more to do things the right
way and I
think people who build exceptional
products think about products the same
way which is like it has to be right it
just has to it's the it's it's all the
100 details it's not the big idea it's
the 100 details that make the difference
between like the Mr Beast videos versus
other people who try to be like Mr Beast
it's the 100 details that make his
videos better yeah it's not like one
caption yeah it's not just the thumbnail
right like it's not that it's a hundred
things I've heard you uh say the word
Joy a couple times and um I'm wondering
if you have a distinction between
happiness and joy and if that's a
helpful thing to
explain um I see Joy a lot as just being
present in the moment because I think
you can joyfully mourn
like if someone's you know died I think
you can there's there's you can find Joy
um in in a Morning Experience if you're
consoling someone else how is that I
think it's just being present and being
okay with experiencing life so I I mean
I that's how I see Joy now I haven't
defined it and I'll probably spend more
time defining the words but
um I just see it as being present like I
am I experience Joy when I am
present like I'm enjoying those I feel
very present right now as soon as you
give up the
goal of
happiness or even
meaning then it stops being this thing
that's outside of you and so it allows
you to be present in the moment and do
what you want to do or do what you need
to do and so if you always have this
thing that you're measuring against one
there's always a Delta between where you
are and where it is but I think often
times it'll optimize for the wrong path
and I think happiness for most people is
pleasure seeking so it they call it
happiness but it's really Hedonism and
most I don't like to appeal to religion
but in terms of old
ideologies most people have found and
I'm sure there is some science that I
don't know um that people who pursue
hedonistic Lifestyles tend to be the
most empty um and the least fulfilled
and so I think people have just swapped
the word happy or hen Hedonism for
happiness and they think they wouldn't
want to say that but if you look at the
actual activities they're pursuing
they're almost purely pleasure
seeking what makes an activity only
pleasure seeking for something that will
build long-term good well I think it's
just time time scale it's short-term
longterm like something that most
pleasure-based activities
are um their pleasure now at the
sacrifice of goal or something later
to be fair I don't think there's
anything wrong with that I'm just saying
like know what we're optimizing
for is that why that um that line that I
think we talked about once of uh desire
is a contract
yourself yeah so um there was this big
philosophy website and then Naval quoted
that site um and it was a desire is a
contract we make with ourselves to be
unhappy until we get what we want
um and
I mean I fundamentally agree whenever
you want something it means you don't
have it and you basically create
deprivation within
yourself to motivate Behavior so if you
see motivation is the equal opposite of
deprivation like you're horniest when
you haven't for a while you are
hungriest when you haven't eaten for a
while you're you have a huge motivation
to sleep when you're exhausted right and
so if we want something we create
deprivation within ourselves to motivate
ourselves to get it but by creating
deprivation we basically create um now
he calls it unhappiness but I don't know
if I necessarily agree with that as the
I think we just we create deprivation
because would you still say there is a
gap between what you have and what you
want sure yeah like you want something
that you don't
have but I mean I think um the the way
to skirt that is in is wanting a
challenge
and so if you just genuinely want to
fight bigger and bigger bosses then the
fact that you get the gold at the end
becomes like if anything the gold at the
end is like irrelevant you just want to
find the next boss and most of the
Champions that are out there that I've
seen you'll have the Michael Jordans the
I mean a lot of Olympians have huge
depression after they get a gold because
now
what and so it really and I think you
can see how people how people react to
Victory tells
you what motivated them or rather what
they were deprived of so if the goal was
to be
exceptional then that person hits the
gold see as sees it as a foregone
conclusion and is just excited to move
on to the next thing if they made their
entire life about getting the gold then
they have no idea what to
do because they were married to the
outcome not the process and again I I
think that you can win either way I
absolutely think you can win either
way but it definitely changes how long
you can play yeah it's like for the
right thing that Gap actually becomes uh
an enjoyable process intrinsically well
it's not it's not even the Gap it's just
that if you want the challenge then you
basically create goals to create
challenges you don't create goals to
achieve goals you you set new goal post
just so that you can have the the trial
and so like someone's like what happens
when you hit a billion I was like I'll
make it 10 and when I 10 I'll hit 100
like it like it it doesn't matter cuz
I'll die and I'll give it all away
anyways it's relevant but it's just like
I want to I want to be
better and the only way to be better is
to do the work that I know I should do
and so that way every day I'm doing the
work and at least for me that has worked
do whatever you want that has worked for
me because I feel like some people talk
about that like moving the goalpost
things and the negative of like oh
people reach one thing and then but I
guess if you take it from the frame of
these are just more challenges that I'll
enjoy from then it's not a problem with
the go
I don't think it's a problem I mean if
you beat level one
boss then what you you the game moves
you up you play harder monsters and then
you try and beat level two boss it's
it's it's this whole fallacy around
being
done it's this whole idea that we can
finish we can work so hard we never have
to work again we can so good we
never have to again we can eat so
big we never have to eat again we can
sleep so well we never have to sleep
again it's just a fallacy it's not true
and people lose their lives trying to
find that one meal or that one or
that one you know uh sleep or that one
goal that'll satisfy them for good and
it never
does I think a story that would really
contextualize this for the audience is
like that period when you were getting
ready to sell gym launch that you just
sound like you felt a little lower oh
yeah so I um so when I was selling gym
launch there was basically a year where
I couldn't really work um mostly because
if I worked in the business then it
would look like I was a key man to the
business and if I
and I didn't know if we were going to
sell so I didn't want to start another
company so I basically just had to like
subsist I could even start new Endeavors
or initiatives within the company so I
just had to do nothing basically and so
for me it was the most depressed I've
been if you look at some of the videos
during that that time period a lot of
them are me being pretty sad and being
like what the is life about but
it's just that for me um like you know
again I'm not religious but I do find it
interesting that the first thing God
gave adam in the Bible before giving him
a wife was giving a
job
work tend to the Garden before he gave
him a wife and I find that really
interesting I don't like religious
religion aside um we're built to work
and so for me especially I'm built to
work and so if I'm working I'm good and
like the the days that I enjoy the most
are the days that I work the longest and
so I just try and remove everything that
stops me from doing that you said
something about hell the other day or
heaven heaven the idea of Heaven
potentially being kind of like a hell
like not not anything oh it sounds
horrible well I mean if the idea like I
think most people
Envision most people Envision heaven
like the one meal that's going to be so
good they're never going to eat again
they're going to be so elated to just be
singing with the angels it's like yeah
but play it out like then
what like okay got it we sang with the
angels at from 9 to 10 and then from you
know then I had the Feast you know what
I mean from 10 to 11 but I got to keep
my my idealized body my my I don't know
Christian needs for idealized body
glorified um physical form I got to keep
that the whole time it's like okay well
now it's noon now what do I do well dogs
are all there cuz all dogs go to heaven
great good to know but if your wife dies
and it's like you have three wives up
there you're like but I mean technically
we were at different time so it's like
what do how do we do with that whatever
God's figured it out but um again I
think it's just this fallacy of work
life balance like I think Heaven is
literally just an extrapolation of work
life balance as a concept which is I
will just be able to do life and no work
but the first thing God does in
the Bible is give someone
work and
so I think so many people would be
helped out if they just stopped labeling
it as a bad thing and started seeing it
as the way to get what they want and
then eventually to make it the thing
they want because the and this is like a
little bit of an app sha idea so it
takes a little bit more processing part
to conceptualize this
but there's goals and then there's
working to hit the goals and then
there's the idea of love the process but
there's the UN the subscript of so that
you can hit the
goal but in my
opinion it's just
work not so that you can it's just
work and it's like what do you mean it
means like working is the goal like
working as hard as you can and learning
how hard you can work and how well you
can work and how right you can make
things and how well you can do them like
pushing that expanding my capacity to
work not so that I can like expanding my
capacity work so that I can work more
like if you can do that then you have
the self-fulfilling
Loop and then you also become completely
divorced from the outcomes which ironic
Al when you do work that way you do have
outsized outcomes compared to everybody
else but you do it because you work so
hard because you're addicted to
working and you like that game and the
goals just happen as a consequence but I
don't even like saying the goals just
happen as a consequence because it still
gives the idea to The Listener or The
Watcher right now that that's the point
and it's not because even if your goal
is to be the richest man in the world
okay let's say that's your goal for how
long every richest man in the world is
Rich for the richest man in the world
for they touch the top and then boom
something changes the economy whatever
it is and then another richest man of
the world comes up like who was the
richest man 20 years ago actually 30
years ago a bunch of Japanese
guys and then Japan's economy crashed no
one even knows their guys names and so
it's
like making the goal even as audacious
as those guys goals were right and let's
say you're number two but even let's say
you're number one for how long and so
that's why I I think that the work is
the goal
not so that you can just the work is the
goal and learning how hard you can work
and being proud of yourself for how much
harder you work today than you did
yesterday you have a tweet that like
perfectly ties us together you hit the
goals that you said you wanted to to be
happy a long time ago yeah is that kind
of what you mean here um actually well
it's it's
um you've already hit goals that you
said would make you happy
and I might have put years ago or
something like that in there but it's
just fun like years ago you set goals
that today you've hit and you said you
would be happy and yet you're not and so
it's because the concept
of setting these goals presumed like the
ultimate
unhappiness equation is uh if I get X
I'll be happy right like we all know
that one um because that's the the the
guarantee of it not not happening
because it automatically the entirety of
your existence is outside of yourself
and then the moment you hit it
then what you set another one then it's
outside of yourself right um and
so if if the
goal doesn't change your entire life
then you can basically be achieving it
every day if the goal is to work as hard
as you can every day you can work as
hard as you can you can be in the state
that you're Desiring if the goal is the
state yeah the goal is the state of
being that you have when you work
exceptionally hard when you do hard work
worth doing and you know if you left
in the tank and I love I think this is
Jesse iler says this but I I I really
love it there's a handful of like saying
that I've gotten from other owners that
I really love I'll give you three right
now I'm side questing but just deal with
it one is um Michael Dell says play nice
but win I just love
that the second one is uh Andy forel has
100 to zero which I really really like
which is basically like society when
you're up you know in football let's say
you're up 30 to nothing and it's
halftime society says put in your put in
your backups put in your third strings
like take it easy and play and he's like
no that 100 to zero step on their
throat and kill everyone and I
like that from a from a perspective of
of like don't let off the gas like just
because they lost doesn't mean that you
now have to dilute yourself to lower
yourself to their
standard and so it's like yeah so what
if
like it takes this much to win I don't
care if it takes this much to win I want
to be here because if if you then change
how you play because everybody else
isn't as good you lower yourself you
don't raise them up that Society trying
to make it appear as though people are
better than they are and I I'm a big fan
of like they should know they lost 100
to zero they should know how much room
they have to improve and also to the
same degree I should know how much
further ahead I
am um and the goal shouldn't even be to
win mhm I'm going to keep playing the
way I play if we happen to finish at 100
to Z we happen to finish at 100 to Z but
I'm not going to let off because that's
who I
am um and the third one was uh Jesse
ller has this thing where he has with
his kids which I really like was um
after they do a marathon because he's
really big in Endurance Sports and so
his kids are too and so whenever they
finish a lot of them pulled up a zero
which I really like and it means nothing
left in the tank he said I just want you
I don't care if you win he's like I just
want you to have nothing left and I I
think about that as like the goal so the
goal is to have nothing left and I think
that on the micro level and on the macro
level like if every day like my favorite
days are the days that I get into bed
and I'm exhausted but proud of
the work that I've done I've have
nothing left I've left it all on the
field and so like that's the goal the
other stuff Society chooses to measure
Me by but when I measured myself that
way it distracted me and I didn't enjoy
my life um but just living that day as
many times in a row as I can until I die
is my plan and at the end on the
macro they want to hold this up and be
like I got nothing
left I'm used up but until then I will
continue to try and be useful and so
that I like I like all three of those
statements and they to me kind of embody
a lot of the the values of one of zero
which is not just doing only what you
can do but doing things that you didn't
you could yet let's say someone wants to
take this Frame of infinite games but
but their thing isn't work like you have
someone like Mother Teresa who's like I
just want to dude i' love exate this
yeah yeah so okay
so Alex what if my goal isn't
work the goal is always work it's just
what you're working
on and so whether you're like I want to
have the best marriage then cool it
takes work if the goal is to
have the best kids then parenting is
that not it's work if
the goal is to have the best physique
it's work if the goal is to have
the best career it's work if the goal is
to just be the ultimate version of you
it's work in all those Arenas and being
mindful of what you want to optimize for
um in terms of how many hours you want
to allocate to each and
so like most people live
lives I mean I'm going to use Rogan's
quote from somebody else but of quiet
desperation because they're hoping to
find a way around work
but work is the way it's the only way
because everything else if it didn't
require work then you'd already have
it breathing doesn't really require work
most people do
it there's plenty of things that we just
don't think about because we have them
automatically and
so everything that you don't
automatically have you have to expend
effort to get
and so everyone just wants a way to get
things without working which I
understand don't get me wrong but the
thing is is that I remember actually
this is a weird thought so I remember
when I was graduating college I had this
um there was like it was like a billion
dollar uh Powerball like I it was like
you know one of when it kind of goes
over a billion dollars and um I bought a
Powerball ticket with my girlfri just as
like a like a fun joke not like I didn't
I was like hoping to win and what's
weird is that I remember remember as the
drawing was happening I I actually had
this huge fear that I
win because if I would win then it would
mean that I would never get a shot to
prove
myself that I that I could have done it
because literally from that point on if
you win nothing you do matters like I
could never prove that I had any metal
whatsoever like everyone would always
say it was cuz you went the
Powerball D and I think the big reason
that I didn't become a physician was
because my dad has a successful practice
and I knew that if I became a physician
it didn't matter how good of a physician
I was it would always be because people
would say it was because of him now that
was then I cared a lot about what people
saying I probably still do um less
though but still on some degree um but
that
was and so just to give I guess the
audience an insight into like how I
think about things if it's valuable for
you like if you are afraid of winning
the lottery
because it won't give you a chance to
prove to yourself who you want to be or
who you want to become then I think
you're on the right
path I love the inverse of that which is
that everything that's right now which
is heart is the opposite of the lottery
is the biggest blessing yeah and
if we were to take this in the equal op
perspective of if winning the lottery is
the ultimate way to not win because you
never get the opportunity to prove
yourself not necessarily prove to other
people but prove to yourself and so
maybe said differently the reason the
the Powerball ter me it's like I
wouldn't be able to prove to me
independent of what other people said
but like I would never know if I could
do it because I had a billion dollars
behind me and so every hardship that you
encounter if you reframe it as the story
that you will someday tell to yourself
of the person that you have become based
on the dragons you've slain and the
obstacles you've
overcome then I think that makes those
obstacles a
unique opportunity for self-improvement
because we can be grateful for these
things I think um I think
Joo has a has a whole bit on this where
whenever something bad happens he says
good and I think it's a great trained
response because if something bad
happens my train response isn't good
it's I will tell the story someday and
so I think if you have that frame then
everything serves you because if
something good happens cool if something
that happens it'll be a story that I
will someday tell because it assumes
that you will live through it and it
assumes that you will eventually figure
it out and so then you can't
lose as long as you don't quit if you're
cool talking about this are these some
of the conversations you have with your
wiser self yeah I haven't actually had a
ton of Solomon conversations recently
because I haven't had a lot of um so
because of the wonderful therapist that
Solomon is I I don't have to stick to a
schedule and so I would say that like
there are
times yeah
so so there's a lot of research that
suggests that we are better at giving
advice than we are adhering to it and so
they've done like as simple example is
they gave two whitewash scenarios of
somebody and told the reader to give
advice to the person who's in the
whitewash scenarios the thing is is that
the person in the whitewash scenarios
was them and they don't adhere to the
advice adhere to the advice that they
give and so they did this to just
demonstrate that people one don't listen
to to their own advice and two that the
advice that people give tends to be
better than what they do and they
postulate that the reason for that is
because you be you can be uh
non-emotional and detached giving advice
to somebody else you can be more
rational about the advice whereas when
you're in it you have more emotions you
make less rational decisions and so
extrapolating that out for me I have a
lot of relatively complex business
dealings that happen on a regular basis
most of my stressors anxieties come from
decisions that I have to to make with
incomplete information and so if I were
to have a therapist I would probably
spend a huge amount of time trying to
catch them up on all the relative
information and then I would hope that
they somehow have the business Acumen to
help me navigate these decisions which
they probably wouldn't and then even if
they did I would have to hope that their
incentive was aligned with mine which
theirs as billable hours not me making
that most money and so there's just a
lot of problems I think with the
traditional model and so at least for me
and so I was like okay well how can I
get somebody who has completely aligned
incentives who has all the same
information as me
um who can give me good advice and
so the person who meets all of those
qualifications is future may and it's
like well yeah wouldn't it be nice to
talk to that person well what's
interesting is if you if you if you
switch your hat around and you're like
okay I'm I'm now future me I'm going to
give advice to younger May um it's a
wild ride but
the dialogue is super powerful because
you don't sugar coat it for you and you
don't need to waste time prefacing and
say like hey take this away like you
don't have to get you just be like it's
such direct
communication um and the advice that I
would get is often advice that I give
and I give really good business
advice only I only say that measured
based on the company's growth that we
have um and so taking that advice
oftentimes I too need to be more patient
often times I too need to keep doing
what has been working oftentimes I too
need to wait until we have enough day to
make the next call um and I have to give
time time and so now some therapist
could say this to me and I'd be like
what the do you know how's your
business going right obviously not that
well you're talking to me for an hourly
rate whatever not that there's anything
wrong with that but I'm just saying that
their goals for business and their level
of aptitude for business is probably not
the same as mine and so it'd be really
hard for me to even put it weight on
their opinion but future me is much
smarter and wiser than I am of course
and so I do weigh their decisions and so
the other piece is that I don't have to
have a generic it's 60 Minutes like why
does why does a therapy session need to
be 60 Minutes it should be as long as it
needs to be or as short as it needs to
be to solve the problem and so I've had
times that it's been 7even minutes I've
had times when it's been 90 I've had
times when it's uh three times in one
week and I've had times where I don't I
don't have to have a quote session with
Solomon for a month
and so it's usually when I'm at big
decision points where I have more
frequent communication to try and like
figure out an issue or a problem but
once once I'm kind of on a path I
usually stay on that Groove for
basically as long as I can and so um
over the last two years I had a lot more
big directional decisions that I needed
to make with kind of the media stuff
that we do and then also the investments
in acquisition doccom but a lot of the
early thesis that we had we have enough
data now that I could make decisions on
them and I have made decisions on them
and so now it's just about sticking to
the plan so what did that process look
like you have a like Google doc and then
you Alterna yeah I just literally pull
up a Google doc I set a date so that I
have all my conversations in one Doc and
um I just hit enter so it's just me him
me him he asks a question I answer like
um and it sounds silly to do this but do
it once and you'll realize that it's
it's weird it it work works for me at
least have you Lo ever looked back on
like what was the first you remember the
first time you did y I do I do I do we
had a we had an unfortunate event that
uh that that had happened that had not
gone the way that IID wanted it to and
um I describe these types of scenarios
as you're a you're a rare baseball card
collector and you have an incredibly
rare card um like super super valuable
and then your 2-year-old when you're
away gets in into the box and destroys
it what do you
do do you hit the kid they don't even
know like what do you do you get upset
at your wife like what do you do you
just got to take it there's no there's
no there's no action you just take it
and so I had I had one of those
incidences from a business
perspective
um and so I just talked to Solomon about
it and he was like you just take it he's
like and you get to tell that story
someday
about the skin that you have and the
things you've gone through and then the
next hard time something happens you'll
be able to compare to that and be like
well wasn't as bad as that right and
then you take measure take measures to
prevent the next card do the best you
can yeah but even when I thought about
that because in that particular
situation it was like okay what
information you know should I have had
or um this is actually a really common
one this happens in investing but like
um people were like I shouldn't have
made that investment or I should have
bought Bitcoin in 2013 well should you
have because the thing is is that if you
have that decision-making framework then
it means that you would have invested in
a hundred other things at that
same time period which means that you
might like that decision-making calculus
probably would have led you to ruin more
than the one time that it worked and
so in order for me to learn from the
experience I have to think about what
what do I change about my
decision-making framework to prevent
something like that happening in the
future and if there wasn't anything that
could really happen in the
decision-making framework then sometimes
you just get kicked in the
nuts sometimes your kid just takes the
Babe Ruth thing and Treads it and
there's nothing you can do about
it yeah and to Loop it back a little bit
it's like if the goal was for you to
enjoy the process of you know even
acquiring that card in the first place
the card collection yeah yeah the
collection isn't really the go M yeah I
mean you're going to die doesn't
matter but yeah I mean I I'm the same
way because I I collect gym equipment
like I love gym equipment and I'll give
it different example um I had a house in
Austin and we had this big really nice
infinity pool that had like this nice
view and somebody came over and was
like Hey be honest with me how many
times do you even use this pool and I
was like I use it five times a day and
he was like what and I was like every
time I walk past it I look at it and I
like it
it's just like somebody saying like Alex
why don't you do more functional
training with your body I was like my
function is to look jacked I use it
every second of every day what are you
talking
about and so it's like and this is
probably a good kind of decision fallacy
to look at because a lot of people will
criticize your decisions because they
use
their way of valuing the decision and
assume it's the same way you value a
decision and so to the gym equipment
thing I have a lot of gym equipment and
I enjoy spending time in my gym like I
like walking in there I like everything
the way it is I like the pieces I
remember how I got them I remember the
workouts I've done on them I'm reminded
of the people I did those sessions with
when I did a brutal whatever and so it's
just a really
positive they're all basically totems of
positive reinforcements so kind of like
the card collection like people go
through their card collection people go
through their car collection because it
reminds them of all the positive things
that have happened um more so than they
collect it because they want to sell it
someday like I'm not going to sell the
gym equipment why would I I like it I
use it but I think I think it follows
along the same thing as like um I enjoy
obsessing about it I enjoy getting
everything right I enjoy the pieces I
enjoy the layout and like I spend way
too much time on it if I only was
optimizing for money which I'm not I
mean it's a component but it's not the
only thing I actually love hearing you
talk about journalism because I think
it's like an interesting look you know
anytime you hear someone talk about
something they love it's like a really
great Insight what do you like like I
hear you talk about strength curves
yeah I feel like we'll do that with the
equipment because it'll make more sense
there yeah yeah but I think I think the
I think at least for me like everybody I
think most
people I'll say this way regardless of
culture all cultures respect
excellence and Excellence comes from
Nuance of understanding and so people
look at bodybuilders for example and
they see them one stage and they're like
oh my God that's so gross and it's
because they don't have
any level of appreciation for the many
things that go into that not just the
effort but even from a product
perspective they're like wow look at how
look at his delts compared to his biceps
look at where his muscle bellies tie in
look at um look at his lat but look how
small he was able to keep his waist
while also building such a big back look
at his vascularity compared to somebody
else who might be more you know grainy
whatever and so they usually even have
the language to describe
what they're seeing and so it's like me
trying different wines it just tastes
like wine you know what I mean but for a
kosur they actually get to enjoy wine so
much more because they have so many more
ways to enjoy it like Eskimos have seven
words for snow and we only have one
because they have more experience with
snow so they have a deeper understanding
of it and so I think most people respect
excellence and Excellence only comes
from depth it comes from exposing
yourself to the same thing for many many
many many periods of time so that you
can pick up those little nuances of you
know what actually if I move my my my
wrist this way when I do this one I get
that little bit at the end and if I if I
change my my chair angle I actually get
this other really cool piece and you
know what if I put my thing on my you
know if I put my dumbbells on my legs
first before I put them over my head I
actually get a different you know
stimulus or whatever it is um and like
that just comes from reps which is why
there's a really great I mean in the
iron game there's a great culture of
passing down these little nuan es and
that's kind of like all apprenticeships
even though it's not a work for a job
well I guess for the top bodybuilders it
is but for most people it's not a
job but there's a there's a craft to it
and I think just being a student of the
Craft um is the
goal you think we've lost some of that
craftsmanship yeah
[Laughter]
100% yeah I mean I mean we've it's just
the crafts have changed you know I mean
like developer wasn't a craft you know
before um I mean shoot making media
wasn't a craft
uh you know quote being an influencer
making content wasn't a craft like these
are all crafts there's just new crafts
that replaced old crafts um but
Excellence is always respected across
cultures and across times like if we go
into the future and there's some new
thing that I've ever heard of but I find
out that this guy's exceptional at it I
will respect him for the effort and so
like chunked down one or chunked up one
um I believe that effort is the
universal currency of respect and so
this is also for the guys who are out
there um who want to be more respected
you will always get respect for
work Chinese Mexican black white asian
gay straight whatever you work your ass
off people will respect you for it now
the problem comes when you think you're
working your ass off but you really
aren't working that hard and that's
where the disconnect is it's be like I
work so hard but it's kind of like the
um like the 10 hours of prep for a
presentation versus 30 it's like you
think you're working hard until you see
what hard looks like and then you're
like I wasn't even working nearly
as hard but I see that as encouraging
because it means that so many people
have so much underutilized potential
because they just haven't even learned
how to work I remember when I did my um
I did a legal internship in France so I
had to do translating legal documents
from French to English um horrible
honestly just terrible work and um uh
yeah I was because I thought because
people were like you're good at writing
you're persuasive you should be a lawyer
and I was like sure I'll try that so I
went to a called ARA um and I did I did
my summer internship there my junior
year and there was this uh partner at
the basically the it was corporate law
but it was equivalent of a partner um
who was there and she walked by my
office and she like I think she might
have talked to me one other time like
just to like welcome me to the office
and this was the only other time she
ever spoke to me and so she uh she like
did one of these like PE peaked her head
into my hole or whatever they where they
kept me to like translate documents and
uh she was like you know how's it coming
or whatever and I was like I was like
man I was like I'm just I'm just working
really hard on this and just trying to
was like just I'm just working really
hard and she just like looked at me and
she just laughed and I was like what the
what and she was like you don't even
know how to
work and I I just
remember thinking that and then and then
she just walked
away and
um and I I I went to the guy who was
like two years above me I was like I was
basically trying you know you'd get his
job as like the lowest level I was like
his peon right and I was like what the
and uh he's like yeah like she like
they work so many more hours than we do
and like have so much higher Stakes than
we do he's like you're just translating
documents dude like if you get something
wrong it's on them not on you and I
remember thinking about that because
like
I thought I was working really hard but
they had to go review everything to make
sure I didn't mess up
and especially in a in a in a job like
law where you usually have billable
hours like you
literally in order to get paid you have
to spend time like it's just like it
just it's just so clearly connected that
those people just kill themselves in
terms of the amount of work that they
they put out
and now that I'm at my at my position
now I 100% C gr like I didn't know how
to work like I was like the idea that I
could work like she was like you don't
even know how to work yet and
um and it was only later that I had a
different guy was like you'll learn when
you get older they're like it just T it
takes time to learn the skill of
effort and so I really genuinely believe
that succeeding isn't
hard learning how to try is hard once
you learn how to try if you just try at
anything compared to other people you'll
win because everyone the bar is so low
to win nowadays even like and I I'll
give the you know the objective stats
for guys it's like if you're the average
guy you're $1,000 in debt you're
overweight and like that's the average
and so like if you're just not in debt
and not overweight you're already above
average like that's it like that's the
that's the bar it's just because no one
knows how to try and no one knows how to
like suck for a little bit and you only
have to suck for a little bit once
because then you learn that sucking for
a little bit has a payoff and then you
can just extrapolate that you know over
and over again but you just have to make
it through the first one but no one's
willing to do that cuz they care so much
about what everyone else thinks and they
feel like they should immediately be
good because that's what social media
tells them when you're working there's
kind of like billable hours and not it's
like there's work that actually counts
and there's work that's kind of just
like work and the ability to
distinguish between that probably
matters a lot
M
um I mean I measur myself on output
based on how much of the work that I do
is correct and done and so I can usually
see if my rate of work has slowed down
um because I've been doing this for a
long enough period of time that I can
tell when my you know if I'm making
slides for a presentation that it's like
my rate of work starts to really drop or
my quality of work starts to drop or
from writing my quality or my speed
starts to drop so like I know when that
happens sometimes it takes longer to get
there sometimes it takes less time um I
think that does take some time I think
in the beginning though you should
expect junk work as in like junk volume
where this is a hard one but you have to
get over it is that while you're still
learning it let's say you reached your
point of Maximum like production at you
know hour five and then you still have
like another five hours of work I would
say do the extra hours of work because
you won't know what that limit is until
you get there and if the next five hours
will work when you come back the next
day you look at it with fresh eyes and
you say like this isn't good enough I
wouldn't see it as a loss I would see
that your ability to see that it wasn't
good enough you would only be able to do
if you had already done the 5 hours of
junk work and that still got you further
ahead than if you hadn't done it at all
and so even if I delete everything I
still have everything in my head so like
for example we've made videos before
where we'll do the entire video and at
the very end we're like I feel like we
could just do that one again and make it
better and then we do it again and it is
way better so it's not the first video
was a waste it was the first video set
up the second video or the first and
second set up the third and so Leeds had
drafts like the 18th set up the 19 18
and it's not that the first 18 were
waste it was just that they were steps
and so it's just that I mean I'll go
biblical on you again um but uh I can't
remember the proverb but it says uh in
all work there is
profit uh which I like the more
rhetorical way of saying like uh the
work works on you more than you work on
it which is that you always benefit from
work in all work there is profit in all
work there is benefit and because like
the five hours extra that you do editing
and then you realize the next day it's
not that that wasn't profitable for you
it's not that you didn't benefit from it
you benefited from it and then once you
benefit from it that comes back out
again and the work benefits and so I
used to say this when I was um growing
business earlier I said either the
business grows or I
grow or both but like one of them is
happening because if the business is
growing great I might not be growing at
all maybe I am but the business is
growing for sure the business stops
growing it's getting hard so I start
growing and then once I grow enough the
business starts growing again and so
like growth is always happening it's
just where you're measuring it right so
let's say someone's been following this
video it's like step one they they broke
the belief that they need to be happy
it's useful you know step two find
intrinsic value in in the process of
improving step three but how like for
you was it going into environments where
you learned you saw people being useful
you saw people working how could someone
do that if they're young and everything
comes down to F figuring out what the
input output equation is if you don't
know the input output equation of
getting good at your skill you will be
lost until you find it and so like if
you want to be a good coder it's $10,000
of coding if you want to be a good
editor it's $10,000 editing you want to
be a good salesman it's $10,000 hours on
the phone if you want to be like it just
is and so for me as soon as I figure
that out then I just want to start
chipping away at it as fast as I can and
so if it's like I can do 10,000 hours
over 10 years or I can do it over four
years
you know it's funny because people see a
200,000 hour work year but there's like
there's so many more hours than that
like it's ridiculous there's so many
more hours than 2,000
hours like there's 104 days of the year
that are weekends and if you add in
federal
holidays and two weeks of paid vacation
you have 129 days a year out of
365 and of the of the remaining days
that you quote work you work eight of
the 24
so like there's so many more hours that
you can that you can do stuff and get
better than people give themselves
credit for and so it's just about see I
was like I was I'm used to add my little
tick for where my ring is um find the
input output equation and then dump as
much as you possibly can into the input
side and get rid of everything that
interferes with it which also means the
people in your life who interfere with
you doing the input out of equation um
the environmental cues so as in like if
you like I work in as as closely as I
can in no windows no sound that's how I
work I don't want any distraction some
people work better with whatever I have
a hard time believing that maybe they
enjoy working more I doubt they work
better some people are like I listen to
music when I
work there's just a ton of research that
shows that that's just like empirically
you work less well like you just don't
now uh instrumental that doesn't have
words words maybe but like you're using
horsepower listening to words period and
so I want all horsepower like even if
you're bouncing on your chair like
you're using brain power and so I want
to use nothing I want to use 100% of my
power on the task at hand and that's it
and and that means that if I have also
stressors outside of my life people who
are bothering me not just like you know
people literally interrupting me but
just problems it's like I want to
resolve those so that I can put all my
attention here because if I'm trying to
type it I'm thinking about you know this
snafu I had with somebody deal with the
snafu and then you'll be able to work
more
clearly what if someone doesn't know
what they want to apply the input into
yet like they don't know that it's
writing they don't know that it's yeah
um I think that it would behoove you so
like everything's so
okay it's the fallacy of the perfect
pick so people think when they're
starting out one that they should find
something they're passionate about um
two that the first thing they pick is
the last thing they're going to do for
the rest of their life and I think both
of those are false so we'll start with
the first one so the fallacy of finding
your purpose or finding your passion
excuse me is that you're going to love
something so much that you immediately
fall in love with it some people do the
vast majority don't and real real I
liked
Fitness but as soon as I started my gym
which I thought was quote pursuing my
passion my life stopped being about
Fitness it was about business and then I
had to learn that and I sucked at it and
so like even the idea that I'm just
going to do my passion isn't even the
reality of quote doing your passion
because doing my passion became work and
I started hiring trainers and getting
systematizing onboarding and getting
them trained up so they wouldn't suck on
the floor because I had to do other
things and all of a sudden I made my
quote passion into
work as other people Define work um and
so
you create passion you don't find it um
and you create it by being willing to
suck for a very long period of time
until you get good and then when you get
good at stuff you tend to like it
one the second fallacy was that you
whatever you is the perfect pick is that
you're going to pick the perfect thing
the first
time life is long people change career
directories more now than ever before
and so
I prefer the process of
approximation which is can I just get
directional and then iterate and so it's
like okay do you like words or do you
like numbers people are like I like
numbers okay all these careers probably
not for you great one directional change
all right and then within there it's
like okay do I Like Money numbers or do
I like data numbers or do I like
computer numbers it's like okay I like
data numbers great so now now we're
already in like a zillion career paths
in this direction but the thing is is
that if you then start getting good at
becoming a data analyst for an oil
company and then you decide that you
want to Pivot into into media buying
there's going to be a lot of
generalizable skills there because it
was all about data and you did have to
learn a lot of stuff and what I will say
is that you get these unique carryovers
that only you will have and so so Steve
Jobs tells a story about how he took
calligraphy right and it seemed useless
at the time and then fast forward when
they had the Mac they started having
different fonts and they only have
different fonts because Steve Jobs that
one time took calligraphy and
so the lessons you learn on the first
thing you do don't become apparent
sometimes until the third fourth or
fifth thing you do but that third fourth
or fifth thing you do the fact that you
did that first thing gives you unique
Advantage compared to everyone else who
didn't and so following the tried andr
path there's nothing wrong with that but
there's also nothing wrong with learning
like there is never a downside to
learning more skills period because you
are able to create more unique
solutions to problems that you get
presented with in the future because of
things you've done in the past and so
I'm sure that like right now there's not
a lot of really jacked
investors there AR but I'll bet you that
there are things that I have taken from
my bodybuilding and powerlifting past
that I can see more uniquely than some
of them can and I know more about
Fitness industry Investments than
probably they do both from a consumer
and from an owner I know like I still
get calls from many many like
multi-billion dollar portfolio owners
they're like hey we're about to invest
in this chain of gyms what do you
think and I've swayed multi-billions of
dollars of decisions being like I think
they're a dog I think they're going to
go down and here's why and they're like
we didn't see that in the data I'm
like yeah but if you were in you'd know
that and so but I wouldn't if I was just
another data analyst they'd never call
me and
so the idea of the perfect pit perfect
pick is just a fallacy so pick a
direction it's just closer or further
this is closer okay cool getting warm
think think about getting warm getting
hot rather than this is it and so then
you can start approximating and the work
that you did on a warm before it gets
hot isn't wasted because you have a new
lens that other people who just went
straight there won't have even if it
takes you longer because again life's
super long Andrew churn and Peggy churn
who started Express they're they're Deca
billionaires now they started their
first location at 40 years ago but he's
75 now so he wasn't like young he was 35
start first location first right
like and they're richer than most people
are or will ever be and so like if it
takes you 10 years or 20 years
um it's fine but I'll also bet you that
they now I have to learn this from them
but I'll bet you they did things before
panda press that had nothing to do with
running Chinese chicken
shops right but those skills still
translated over I was a Management
Consultant at space cyber and
intelligence for the military before
starting a gym how does that translate
well I learned a Consulting process and
the learning of Consulting process is
learning how to solve problems and so I
use that with my gyms because the
Consulting process you go to experts and
you ask them what they do so I started
interviewing all these gym owners
because they were willing to talk about
their gyms and I would drive out there
every weekend because I had time and I
would just spend time with the gym and
I'd be like how do you onboard people
what do your contracts look like what
terms do you use how do you do with
cancellations how do you do with turn
how do you do with the cin cards and I
would ask all of them and every once in
a while some be like oh I do that that's
good I'll take that one down I'll steal
that from me and I would just do that
over and over and over again but I got
that from Consulting other gym owners
didn't apply Consulting for him because
they weren't Consultants first so if I
had maybe started straight into gym
ownership right out of college rather
than taking two years to be a consultant
I might not have gone as far so like
what felt like a complete waste of time
when I was in it which it
did might have been the thing that made
me succeed in the next thing and so even
if you're in it right now the only thing
that I can say is that you want to try
as hard as you can and get as many
skills as you can in that field even if
you don't think you're going to use it
later and I'll wrap this with this um if
you guys haven't seen it it's it's a
worthwhile movie it's something called
um Slum Dog Millionaire so the premise
of the movie is this kid in the slums in
India um it basically just tells his
story of just like trials and
tribulations he just says bad luck after
bad luck after bad luck the whole movie
and then by chance at the end of the
movie he gets on their equivalent of uh
Who Wants To Be A Millionaire and so I
think it's like 12 questions or
something it's 12 or 20 I don't remember
questions that they
ask and by
Chance the haphazard crazy bad
situations that this guy is in his whole
life amount to him winning and and
answering each of the questions
correctly and so a lot of times we just
need to expand the time Rison and
realize that we might be playing our own
Slum Dog Millionaire movie it's just
that we're in like the third we're we're
learning the answer to the third
question right now even though we're
just getting kicked in the
nuts and so I think if you have that
frame
and remember that the worst thing that
can ever happen is that you die and
you're going to die no matter
what it lowers the stakes a little
bit dude D Man